the 71st Primetime Emmy Awards went down
on Sunday night but if you weren't one
of the lucky ones to score a seat inside
the star-studded theater there were some
serious moments the cameras missed now
we're breaking down the 7 biggest
moments that didn't make it to TV
starting with this but there's only one
category it was singing and dancing and
death-defying after Adam Devine slayed
his musical number he made his way
backstage where a bunch of people told
him that his bit was hilarious naturally
Adam being the witty wild gent that he
is he quipped that presenter lin-manuel
Miranda needed to start working on the
sequel to his hit Broadway musical
Hamilton Adam Devine in a lin-manuel
Miranda musical yes please about a half
hour into the show queer eyes Antony tan
and Bobby B lined it to the lobby during
a commercial break to catch some air
unfortunately for Antony he barely made
it outside before he was stopped by a
ton of fans wanting to take a selfie
then there's this fashion moment
twinning
Marisa Tomei and taraji P Henson or both
rockin hot pink and red gowns and when
they spotted each other backstage they
could not help but gush over their
matching looks Marisa even shouted we're
in the same gown what makes this moment
extra cute is that the two have appeared
on empire together loves it a few
minutes later taraji was seen joking
around backstage with her Empire co-star
Terrence Howard while presenters Gweneth
Paltrow and Kristen Bell hugged each
other and caught up nearby I am feeling
all this love and I'm super super here
for it
beep star Timothy Simmons totally geeked
out when he met lin-manuel Miranda
backstage and he even told him that he
was a huge fan way to keep her cool man
JK I totally get it
I'd be starstruck ni BMS
number two on our list while Lauren
Michaels didn't make any mention of the
controversial hiring and firing of
Shayne Gillis after racist and
homophobic comments surfaced the
Saturday Night Live cast and crew were
noticeably subdued as they walked
backstage after winning the Emmy for
Outstanding variety sketch series and
that sort of thing is what keeps us
there that and the politics former SNL
star Bill Hader addressed Shane's firing
when et caught up with him backstage
yeah I just feel like you shouldn't want
to hurt anybody's feelings you know it's
Betty but I think also you know
especially in comedy you do stuff six or
seven years ago that wouldn't be okay
now and probably for good reason you
know what I mean so I think a lot of us
are you know like I only speak for
myself but there's you know like
everybody you have to kind of grow and
last but not least with an hour left to
go in a three-hour ceremony
Regina king who presented the in
memoriam was overheard telling Anthony
Anderson that she was ready to take off
her heels and get the party started at
the after parties listen I'm a girl
about comfort so I see you Regina and I
feel you as for those after parties it
was all about the love a few of my
favorite moments Phoebe Waller bridge
and Rachel Brosnahan gave each other a
major squeeze at the Amazon Studios
afterparty Julia louis-dreyfus laid a
big old smooch on her veep co-star Anna
Chlumsky cheek at the Governor's Ball
and then there's Kit Harington and
Emilia Clarke who were all smiles at the
Netflix afterparty god I love an award
show of course you can count on et to
bring you all the behind the scenes
Intel so make sure to subscribe to all
things et until next time I'm Hallie
Stevens bye for now
[Music]